the family of late jeopardy host alex  trebek has donated much of his on-stage  wardrobe  to the doe fund the doe fund is a  nonprofit helping men who struggled with  homelessness incarceration or addiction  with housing  training and even clothes for job  interviews  i feel real good i feel proud that i got  a celebrity suit  keep on giving you know he that's what  he did well i'ma do the same thing  and that was george tucker he just was a  recipient as well from one of the suits  and  he's turning his life around after 20  years in prison  on trebek's final jeopardy episode he  says if we all pitch in just a little  bit we can build a gentler  and kinder society